what's the one-year anniversary gonna be
like a mine I don't know I asked and I
was told why do you ask so many
questions
because he's the planner so you know
he's gotta sleep okay I'm gonna let you
plan it Nick Jonas may be the planner in
his marriage to Priyanka Chopra but we
got a handed to pre for pulling off this
seriously epic surprise
yep just a week ahead of their first
wedding anniversary Priyanka surprised
her hubby with a cuddly canine a German
shepherd named Gino both Nick and
Priyanka shared the adorable moment on
their Instagram accounts the singer
called Gino the absolute best surprise
and said he hasn't stopped smiling since
he woke up this morning and get this the
dog even has his own Instagram account
already it's been incredibly exciting
ét sat down with Nick earlier this month
where he opened up about his upcoming
anniversary and reflected on his first
year as a married man I don't want to
say what we're doing to celebrate
because it's a surprise for her and she
might be watching and if she is then you
know I wouldn't want the surprise to be
spoiled but we will be taking a few days
away from the tour just to have some
time it's been a crazy year
you know it's flown by it's hard to
believe that was a great couple days
celebration and it's flown by this
year's been I think for she and I both
probably the craziest of our lives but
really nice to kind of have that
centering grounding feeling with each
other and Priyanka told et in October
how she wants to celebrate the milestone
I would love to make sure we get time
with each other but also with our family
and friends like it's such a monumental
day in both our lives that we would love
to have a loved ones around us too
we'll have to wait and see how Nick and
Priyanka officially celebrate their
first anniversary on December 1st but
one thing is for sure these two are the
definition of couple's goals we both
really enjoy talking to each other which
i think is probably important if you
marry somebody so you know there aren't
as like rules about how long we can go
and things like that I think we just we
we always just do the absolute best we
can and and understand you know first
and foremost that we love what we do as
well and we won't support each other in
that and she's out there making a movie
that's gonna be amazing
it's it's it's a great thing to have a
creative partner who totally understands
your schedule as well and we're both
very supportive in that sense
[Music]